- Speaking of traveling,
so you had some car
issues, was it in Monaco?
- Oh, at Monaco. Yeah.
- What happened?
And first of all, bravo,
just like driving in a different country.
- Oh, I was not.
- Oh, I was like, "I don't do that."
- I'm pretty much the
worst driver in the world,
in America, in anywhere.
- So wait, what happened then?
- Like I live very close to here
and I was like, "I'd rather
walk here than drive."
- Do you have a bike?
- I'm a menace to society,
way too ADHD.
Yeah, we were in Monaco
and we were leaving an event
very early in the morning.
We're like four.
And we, I don't know how
somehow ended up on the track
for the Grand Prix in Monaco,
and they were all like coming on
and bringing all the cars
on for the Grand Prix.
So we got stopped and
got pulled over by the,
there we are, see.
You can sort of see like a glazed
over drunk look on my eyes, essentially.
- How does one accidentally
get on the Grand Prix?
Like that's-
- I think the driver thought
it was exciting, to be honest,
or we had something to do with it.
- Or you had a really
good inebriated idea,
"Let's go."
- "Let's go in the track"
- "We are a race car driver."
- Yes, exactly.
- That's hilarious.
And four in the morning,
oh my God, I'm too old.
That just sounds exhausting. Okay.